hey guys righteous Ryan here that should
have been my youtube name no my name is
Ryan Wright and today I'm gonna be
watching the trailer or male ficient I
don't give a [ __ ] what you say that is
how you pronounce it I felt like 15
billion people tell me how to correctly
pronounce it and Maleficent I know I
know I don't know why I'm acting like
I'm upset about her I'm the one who
asked if you guys can tell me how to
pronounce it I need to stop doing this I
am running late for work
again I was working on something last
night which did not allow me to watch
this trailer but a lot of you guys are
really asking me to watch it so here I
am running late for work again the best
excuse in the world or my boss is I had
to watch a trailer boss sorry you can't
be on time because people want me to
watch this trailer so thank you guys
thank you guys it's a great excuse I've
seen a lot of trailers for this damn
movie already the first couple I didn't
really care about third one was really
good
you know honestly I'm just gonna watch
it because Angelina Jolie it looks like
she's having one hell of a good time
plus damn oh I want to do sexual things
to her I saw the movie um taking lives
with her and Ethan Hawke in the theaters
with my mom and there's a sex scene that
was just so hot which is very
uncomfortable to watch with your mom
right next to you and then I also saw
original sin with her Naito name and
eros and there's a lot of sex scenes in
that one and I saw that one with my dad
nothing beats getting an erection next
to both of your parents while watching
Angelina Jolie have sex all right let's
do this it's rated PG for sequences of
fantasy action and violence including
frightening images this sounds like one
hell of a kid's film violence and
frightening images nothing likes scaring
the [ __ ] out of little kids
come on okay there we go creepy dance is
so sexy even with those horns I shall be
still
it's seen so wonderfully cheesy I love
it this one looks a lot better than when
I first saw it and did trailer curious
little basting
I know you're there don't be afraid I'm
not afraid then come out and you will be
afraid
at least she's considerate of her
feelings avatar from me
there is evil in this world
sounds like today I wanna do things to
her so God
our on those who live in the shadows
oh [ __ ]
kinda looks like Jack the giant slayer
that's pretty cool
mail fishin actually Smallman mail
ficient IMAX any film on IMAX is worth
watching most of the time I like the
last trailer more but that's a pretty
damn good trailer I definitely am going
to be watching this you know I I liked
Alice in Wonderland ah I didn't care
about Snow White in the hunt and I
thought that was a really boring film I
definitely want to check this out it
looks like it's cheesy but dark at the
same time it just looks like it's gonna
be a fun film you know and I like movies
that are just entertaining it might not
be the deepest thing Angelina Jolie
looks like she's totally hamming it up
and you know I I love watching a
celebrity who's just having a great time
on screen I mean it is it is seems a
little cheesy especially when she's
shouting like oh no 16th birthday one
thing is pretty funny to me is Sleeping
Beauty does not look interesting to me
at all like Princess Aurora no interest
in her it's all about Maleficent but one
thing that does kind of bother me about
this is it looks like that Angelina
Jolie is not the villain she looks like
she's actually a protagonist in this and
I like the idea of her being the main
antagonist it looks like they have
someone else to be the battered person
or something I don't know I just
preferred it when the focus was on the
villain I thought that was pretty cool
maybe I'm wrong I don't know it's just a
trailer who knows anyway guys I'm
running late for work but if you're new
to the channel subscribe I don't know
where the button is actually let's
subscribe if you're new to the channel
subscribe suggest more trailers if you
suggest a trailer just know I will
eventually get around to it I just have
about 50 trailer requests literally I
write them all down I got about 50 this
being one of the 50 and so I will get
around to them I'm playing and watching
all of them I don't have time to watch
three minutes of a trailer all the time
I love people who make excuses like that
I don't know time to watch a trailer and
it's like it's like a couple minutes but
you know and I'm totally making that
excuse for why I'm not ditching all
these out you guys know in the movie
wanted that was not Angelina Jolie's
asked that we saw it was a butt double
still I like to do things to Angelina
Jolie's but